Bây giờ chúng có báo người bị một tháng 15 tại Tây Ran, người phân ngôn bộ ngoại giao i RUN SMAU, Bà Gayi,
Bác bỏ phát ngôn của tổng thực hiện nè tô mắt vốt, người cáo bộ i Ran và Ngà Hợp Tác, để phá hoạc các quy tác của tế.
Ông bà Gayi nhấn mạnh các cáo bộ này là vô sả chi và phản nắng sự mâu thận trong chính xét của nè tô.
Theo ông, biểu xem xét càng đậm thực tế, xí cho thấy, ai là bên thường xuyên vi phạm lượt phát của tế,
i Ran cáo bộ Mỹ và một số nó thành định nè tô, người mắt đầu định khu vực, viện giắn các chính xét của sự về thường vòng dân sự.
Tây Ran khẳng định nơi ngay hôm tôn chẳng hiện chương lên được quốc và mong muốn thúc đẩy đối thoại thay vì đối đau.
Đồng thời cho rằng nè tô đăng tìm cách chuyển hướng chú ý hỏi những mẫu thận nội bộ trong khối.
Chứ đá hoang ngày tổng thực hiện tổng hiếp bớt bắt đại tây dừng nè tô mắt lúc,
tôm giọc các khu giọt thành viên, con cường xảm sốt bố khí, nè sẵn sản chương một đối đau kéo dài,
mới đi măng ngay hạ chương quốc ý Ran và chương tiên, những khu giá mà theo ông là đang thách tước tờ cuối tắt bọn cầu.